breve a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fa vj oggi e
domenica quindi siamo su happy vis
livello a caso non sarà che cosa ho
cliccato ma voluto iniziare così welcome
to gray che ragazzi dobbiamo spaccare
metri poi non fai vedere chi sei
praga e voi non lo sapete ma non lo so
che la giovane era un vandalo ce lo
hanno aspettato la cosa e fischiando la
mia sedia a rotelle
come pensi di andare vieni qui niente ci
consegnata non so perché mi infatti
tasso di a rotelle mi sta scoprendo una
sedia
ragazzi vi presento nonno ciak 2.0
questa nuova versione è già il mio dio
che lombardo non ci posso credere
questa notazione di non non c'è cos'è
questo faccio spaccare vetri in basso
raga impossibile perché c'è ancora una
gamba che mi segue che lo annuncia il
signore e signori la possiamo fare ci ha
posto a fare io mio non è così né senza
testa se stanno morto all'ultimo chi se
ne frega io racconto come vittoria
perchè sono bello lai qualcosa mi dice
che si vola in questo livello
c'è nonno ciak di nuovo non c'è che la
strada verso l'infinito e nonno ragazzi
vorrebbe che passo di danza di nonno
ciak guarda ma c'è una fine e sono
arrivato alla fine ma non ho vinto avvio
vinto grande nonno visi sparta questa
settimana a tuttosport ha praticamente
ce l'avevo già fatto quel che resta è
sparta no brutto stronzo non cade invece
non cado le mie gambe ma devo riuscire a
non cadere aspettate in atti non voglio
cadere brutto stronzo non voglio cadere
sì ma non ti incazzare però va bene se
volevi che cadessi a tutti i costi va
bene ciao nonno che avete la pace qui
sotto survivor da fall sopra via la
caduta non ci devo sopravvivere con uno
ciak
no no no non è il diritto di buttarti
senza di me cosa fai gli occhi cosa mi
tiri calci brutto bambino di merda cosa
fai che cazzo fai uk ragazzi no no
maledetto ogni occhio schiacciato il
sellino questa te la faccio pagare
giusto la star do
vabbè mi sono tagliato a metà andato non
va tranquillamente e troll facciamo
questo perché mi ispira al nome sono col
padre di hughes ero col padre di uk ce
la faremo ragazzi non è così difficile
polle l ho un cazzo sono sono fra vivo
sono ancora vivo non si sa come sono
ancora vivo va bene con una gamba sola
senza agli occhi è sempre meglio quindi
sono vivo sono ancora vivo sono sempre
vivo cioè mi stanno triturando ma non
partono i proiettili perfetto quindi
sono 98 ram non era un bottone tutto
finto mi stanno prendendo per il culo
ho visto che facciate assurda so parte
ii soma l'enigmista penso si infatti
devo scendere porca [ __ ] crisi scende
spacca steve e triste spacca strimenti
sala giochi prima che tocchi a te
maledizione come faccio
no no no se non altro la tipa gnocca vai
steve togli sto male altissimo vetro
bravo skip ce l'abbiamo fatta finalmente
cos'è è una seduta per guardare le
bottiglie parla capita voglio la mia
birra
voglio la mia [ __ ] birra adesso non
me ne vado di qui finché non ho la mia
piena cognizione
dio di crazy sheikh cos'è sta roba cos'è
sta roba mi fa così schifo
cioè non si sa come mai si muove così ma
va bene grande hai messo la testa in
lavatrice
mai così dobbiamo raggiungere system poi
si sappia delfino no mio dio mi si sa
perché nutella questa cosa gli hotel a
quest ragazzi questo mi piace cioè di
dorme pensa la nutella questa è la cosa
più strana che abbia mai visto su happy
meals c'è una cosa assurda va bene di
andiamo a cercare la nutella se lo vuoi
all'inizio tutela bravo ed lo dico
sempre anche io comunque non la trova
mai dover antella devo andare a cercare
la nutella sì andiamo cerca la nutella
steve sarà epico e grazie per aver
giocato
[Musica]
sbaglio o era un po più corto di come mi
aspettavo toilette race 9 per questo chi
l'ha fatto un genio ragazzi devo trovare
la posizione ecco forse l'ho trovata
questo è il miglior modo per fare la
cacca ragazzi non fatelo a casa comunque
la vittoria
cosa vuoi no no non me ne frega niente
sei perso torna gioca forse vuoi che
posso livello perché l'ultima volta ne
ho fatti pochi facciamo mi manca ecco mi
manca tipo lops bing facciamolo psuv in
questo robin good wife iconico sei
veramente un fico robbie su inter fa
vigera che ce la possiamo fare
via così è di farci vedere chi sei fa
vigeva vj famiglia haifa vj o ma c'è per
caso scritto fa vj
nel caso comunque non si era notato per
niente c'è questo volevo soltanto dirlo
perfetto ciò fatta no no no mio dio mi
sono spezzato la schiena ma sono ancora
direi più la gamba però va beh non
importa andiamo avanti ragazzi ce la
possiamo farcela possiamo fare la gamba
sta vincendo
raga io sì sì sì all
sulla gamba direttamente perfetto gran
livello ravi sono sicuro che questo non
riuscirai a finire mi prendi per il culo
vero tu mi stai prendendo per il culo
questa si chiama presa per il culo
perché non è possibile che non riesco a
fini non impossible dovresti saperlo
favino riesce a fare questo
edigita convinto quiz sul po vj ragazzo
ho paura di che cosa sto per andare a
leggere ciò veramente paura cioppa vj tv
o chi sta giocando il mio livello questo
è un quiz su fa vj tv
vabbè valigia è stato prima italia fare
renderman ho mancato bersani questo ce
la posso fare allora non è così
difficile se solo le mie cose giusto la
so questa giusto grazie mille beh ho
studiato devo andare avanti perfetto
grazie aver messo i materassini mi è
molto più comodo no perché ogni volta mi
spezzo le gambe quando faccio sti
livelli la sua ragazza perché c'è un
cuore lì perché c'è un [ __ ] cuore
dopo la mia ragazza perché c'è un cuore
a terra speciale 75mila iscritti ha
giocato gioco tranquillo come cat mario
io risponderei sì però a moquette mario
quindi vado sulla seconda è la storia
d'amore tra mac e mario è così infinita
che era quella giusta era quella giusta
e pensavo di sbagliare va bene per
ultima domanda si chiama luca oppure
lorenzo io scelgo oppure no non si rompe
questa balla andiamo su lorenzo va
meglio così no kat
a sto sbagliando bene non sono fatto
tornare indietro michelot e ultima
domanda negli anni nell'anno e shake
tanto atteso ci sono tre famiglie io due
fa vj o c'è una o quattro fa vj
re pochi j
ha vinto devo prendere il mio premio una
monetina
così gli compro le caramelle ragazzi
questo è il mio premio grazie mille so
tutto su di me i ragazzi di race
includere qui l'episodio come al solito
stè vito è piaciuto lasciato un commento
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook e
come non di video trovate nella
descrizione 6 riscritti iscrivetevi noi
ci rivediamo in un prossimo video belle
ragazze
[Musica]